so lately I've been watching quite a bit
of MORTAL KOMBAT 11 and a few people
have asked me to cover the loss
surrounding some of the newer characters
and there are some new additions that I
think are pretty cool so today's video
will be on Gareth and there will be some
spoilers so if you've not played through
the game or watched the story I guess
now is when you click off the video
Garrus is one of this year's new
additions to the MK franchise he was
created by Kronecker who is referred to
as a Titan and who serves as the
antagonist to this year story his role
in the story is as chrono cos main
enforcer her right-hand man and given
that she did create him Garris is able
to control the sands of time similar to
his master but to a lesser extent we
know that he can go back in time but
whether he can see the future and go
forward in time is unclear he can also
use the sands to form objects such as
tables or walls to block and crush his
enemies the sands can also take the
shape of weapons such as hammers and
swords and what looks like a golden
Hellboy fist - well fist anyone who gets
in his way
in Garris can even turn himself into
sand making him much harder to kill with
that being said Garris can be killed as
you would normally expect but the issue
is he doesn't stay dead for very long
because he can rewind time - before he
died and he also seems to have some form
of accelerated healing each time he's
killed he comes back stronger and
smarter with an immunity to whatever
killed him very similar to what we see
with doomsday in Superman we don't
really know how old garrus is for sure
considering the whole immortal lifespan
but it is mentioned that he has died
thousands of times and has witnessed
many of the key events throughout
history such as the Ice Age so he could
be anywhere between thousands and
millions of years old we do see Garris
several times throughout the story first
when he is decapitated by Koon Lau's
razor hat only for his head to turn into
sand and re materialize back on his body
the next time we see him he's killed by
one of Cassie cages grenades only to
once again reform like nothing happened
in the first place the last time we see
Jairus is in his defeats to Raiden where
he is bound by a chain with an anchor
attached and thrown into the blood Seas
he tells Raiden that it's essentially
pointless because he cannot die from
drowning either because this has already
happened or because he plans on
rewinding time most likely the first but
the blood Seas are pretty much just a
bottomless pit
so he's condemned to sink forever with
no chance of escaping without assistance
a pretty good example of where he's in
mortality can be used against him before
I go I'll leave you a quick bit of
mythological trivia garrus is actually
the name of the god of old age in greek
mythology and given the character's
immortality and the fact that he was
created by Kronecker a Titan whose name
sounds awfully familiar to Cronus it
certainly seems like a slight nod in the
direction of some of these Greek stories
overall I think Garris is an awesome
looking character and he has a pretty
interesting set of abilities even if he
is just a time-traveling doomsday who
can smash people through tables made of
sand and fists them of his Infinity
Gauntlet if you are an MK fan and you'd
like to see more videos similar to this
one or if there are any characters in
specific that you'd like to see then let
me know in the comments below as always
I've been your host mythology and
fiction explained